I don't know if you've noticed her hand
but she's engaged congratulations to uh
you said a a childhood friend yeah um
Rory you you really know that you know a
lot no you told me I didn't even
ask it's a nice ring you go this is Rory
a childhood friend you've met him before
he's really nice really sweet I did meet
him before when he told me his name I
looked him up and I remember meeting him
he's a really nice guy and do you have a
date set well because I've got an MBE I
have to now go to the um what's it
called Lou the parish the church the
church the main person the main person
you go to the main person go to the main
person and then they give me king the
king what no but they give me the priest
that's it the priest then they give me a
date really that's the word you were
looking for they give me a DAT and then
I can get married where Princess Diana
got married like in the whole the
because you want to or because that's
now what you have to do because I don't
have to do it but that's one of the
perks of getting a oh you can get
location location location yeah and so
you'll get married in that
big Cathedral Cathedral Cathedral say
Johns and and um I also read that uh
Victoria is gonna make you a gown for
that well I'm gonna have lots of cat I'm
going to have lots of gowns I think what
do you mean no a lot of people do that a
lot of people have multiple dresses
so she's going to be one of them no so
you have the church gown and then say
you want to do it again like in a hot
country you have that gown then you
change into another gown and then you
have you know the dinner gown there like
gown after gown no so you don't want to
be in gown the for the whole entire day
oh I know so there's an outfit that's a
little more casual no well not where
where I'm concerned I'm going to have
like more gowns you're gonna have a lot
of gowns none of which are casual
no and and part of the wedding in this
time will be casual like suspenders and
stuff suspenders suspenders yeah like
having SE that's like having sex with
Larry King no no well you you call them
I call them suspenders you know gers GS
no not
suspenders suspenders call suspenders no
suspenders are what old fat men wear to
hold their not that what are they called
like I don't know what you're they
called something richel no cuz he's a
pervert the thing
is oh your girlfriend's there oh well
that's nice
sorry the thing is what are they called
G Gars I think I'm right called gers
gers huh no the strap thing not a Camal
a strap where you have to hold your
thingy up yeah g belt Kyle knows I don't
think it's a garter belt it's definitely
not suspender I swear to God we call
suspenders I'm feeling a little hot go
get the suspenders call suspenders you
can probably hold them up with
suspenders you know but if you just you
do that so then that out have an image
of Larry King with crotchless boxers on
so then you have your bedtime outfit
which is a bit more casual that's not
different gowns there's one wedding gown
and then you change always one so were
you given a date yet and if you are I
have to go and see the priest when I get
back the 30th of October yeah I remember
that that's good 30th of October going
to see the priest and he'll give you a
date wait that that already passed oh
maybe it's 30th of September oh yeah oh
you missed it September October you
missed the DAT November November no no
that's too it's too late it's October
it's too late it's the 30th of October
it's the 22nd now oh the 30th not the
13th the
30th three Z the 30th I haven't missed
it okay it's in my diary in your diary
you know you have alert a journal like
oh do you have a diary oh on your
calendar yeah so I haven't missed it no
and are your kids going to March like do
you do you do that is it going to be
like a like did they March well what do
you mean March I don't know is like one
of them the flower girl what do you call
it you I'm going to stuff like that yeah
I hav decided everything yet I haven't
decided everything no because it'll just
make me panic
[Music]
it